a Wall Street Journal with an amazing
piece that caught my eye last night so
we had to have one of the reporters on
it how one tweet turned pro-china trolls
against the NBA written by Georgia
Welles Tom McGinty and our next guest
Ben Cohen from The Wall Street Journal
how are you Ben I am okay thanks for
having me you got it so lay it out for
me what did what did you endeavor here
in this article for those who might not
have read it well we wanted to see
exactly what happened once Daryl Morey
pressed sand on that infamous tweet
about ten days ago and was quickly
swarmed by replies and you know became
like you know the most interesting man
in geopolitics for a few days shockingly
and you know I think anyone with eyes
could see that these accounts that were
telling him that his mother was dead and
had zero followers and had never tweeted
before there was something fishy going
on here and so what we were able to do
and using the data from a couple of
Clemson University researchers was
analyze about 170,000 tweets that were
sent at him over the course of a week
after that first tweet and what we found
was that a startling sort of astonishing
number of them came from accounts with
zero followers came from accounts that
didn't exist until he sent that first
tweet and what people who look at this
for a living these disinformation
researchers say is that you know they
have never seen anything like this that
is not affiliated with a state operation
and so essentially that these were
pro-china trolls not just BOTS but like
you know possibly even humans at a
keyboard who were sort of targeting him
in this harassment campaign meant to
manipulate the conversation about China
and Hong Kong so you know that that
tweet started this whole thing and you
know this whole thing has just sort of
been so misunderstood and and and hard
to grasp in real-time and so you know
just looking at exactly what happened
from the beginning and putting some
numbers to it and actually crunching the
data seems like a pretty good place to
start
and so what did
the data tell you Ben does it does it
point in the direction obviously the
Chinese government must have been the
ones to orchestrate all this is that is
that fingerprint been discovered this
well that's what it appears I mean it's
hard it's hard to it's hard to say that
definitively what one of the researchers
says is that he's only you know he's
only seeing this type of behavior when
it is state backed but you know just
looking at the numbers it's they kind of
speak for themselves I mean 50 percent
of these tweets that were sent at him
had came from accounts with fewer than
13 followers like almost four thousand
tweets didn't even he almost four
thousand and the accounts didn't even
exist until he sent his first tweet I
mean so you know he was bombarded by a
hundred and seventy thousand tweets that
at the peak of this troll activity they
were appearing at his phone at a rate of
like nearly two per second which you
know you just think about like if you're
actually trying to keep up with your
Twitter replies on your phone to get a
hundred and seventy thousand I mean it's
just astonishing and and the fact that
so many of them seem to spout pro-china
rhetoric so you know an anti Hong Kong
sentiment when the organic discussion if
you take out those accounts that had
zero followers and appear to be linked
with China it's actually the opposite
there was a lot of support for Daryl
Morey and a lot of support for the Hong
Kong protest so they were trying to make
it seem like the discourse was balanced
when in fact it really was not Ben Cohen
Wall Street Journal columnist here on
the Rich Eisen show so if we are
assuming then that it was state backed
the question is is what's the chicken or
the egg here is it is it that the
Chinese government saw this or a member
of the Chinese government saw this and
then immediately got approval to hit
send from all of these BOTS or from this
disinformation campaign to back what
they were going to do with the NBA or
did all of this stuff happened
by a proxy and then the government just
came in and and and wanted to use this
for whatever campaign they have against
Hong Kong I'm wondering what what what
to make of all your information here Ben
yeah I mean it's a fascinating question
rich and I have to admit that as an NBA
reporter I was not all that well briefed
on you know Chinese disinformation
campaigns until last week so I'm not
entirely an expert on this but I think
what's interesting here is that this
effort aligns with you know China's
state institutions breaking with the NBA
and the Rockets at around the same time
so if you remember I mean the I know is
only ten days ago now or two weeks but
the you know the the big streaming
network their state television both cut
ties with the Rockets the people's daily
the Communist Party news to Brenna and I
know that it's absurd to be talking
about this on on you know a show about
sports and knows it's just it's it's
it's wild that we're like talking about
like communist newspapers and how they
attacked an NBA general manager but all
of this sort of happened at the same
time so it's hard to sort of separate
all this stuff because it does appear to
be an institutional push and it's sort
of hard in America to wrap our heads
around the fact that all of these all of
these sports institutions in China are
backed by the government right these
they sort of moved as one and so so I
you know I think that this Twitter
campaign was probably part of it you
know we this is what the evidence
suggests right I mean we can't say
definitively but I think if you sort of
look at the numbers and use your brain
that's you know that's that's how you
come out thinking about this well then
you know I'm part of the reason why I'm
having you on here Ben Cohen in The Wall
Street Journal and discussing what we
are discussing and as you say it's kind
of crazy we're talking about communist
papers and things like that on on a
sports show if you will is that this
could cost the job of an executive of
the year who puts together Hardin and
Westbrook for an organization that could
win the NBA championship right now who
just bestowed upon him because of how
terrific he is at his job
long-term contract because a tweet got
blown up by a whole bunch of bots
because he strolled into a geopolitical
story that is so monumental it involves
the President of the United States
President G LeBron James Adam silver
Nike I mean Warner Brothers movies I
mean it is insane how many parts of our
world this touch has been and don't
forget like all of this happening
against trade negotiations and a tariff
war that could disrupt the global
economy you're totally right it is it's
absurd that it has come to this but I do
think it's I mean I struggle to think of
a more consequential story for the NBA
in a very long time and in terms of like
geopolitical implications in terms of
the tension that existed here for a
while in terms of the magnitude of the
crisis I mean it's it's one of the most
consequential and also the most bizarre
episodes I think maybe even in the
history of American professional sports
I mean I don't know how you really top
this well there's a couple of other
things I want to hit with you before I
let you go from your piece again as you
point out you cover the NBA for Walt The
Wall Street Journal you're not really an
expert on again international
informational warfare but here's the
cart achill you wrote or with your
colleagues when it comes to information
warfare China tends to be defensive and
engage on issues relating to sovereignty
according to the researchers while a
country like Russia is more aggressive
and inflames online discussions of
polarizing topics such as NFL
quarterbacks kneeling during the
national anthem and you quote one of the
researchers is saying they meaning
Russia don't care about Colin Kaepernick
they just want you to talk about Colin
Kaepernick have they found that the
Kaepernick issue was inflamed by Russia
they is that been confirmed by these
folks yeah and in fact they have my
colleague Andrew Pete and wrote a great
story for the journal right around this
time last year using some of these some
of this research from these same
professors who looked at tweets that
were backed by Russia and found that
like among the many people who were
talking about Colin calf
or continue to talk about colin
kaepernick were Russian trolls on
Twitter and you know that was them going
out of their way to show discord in the
United States whereas China tends to
like China got involved in the NBA
because an NBA general manager tweeted
about Hong Kong protests and you know
that is a third rail issue as you know
most NBA fans know by now in you know
and and you know but Colin Kaepernick
has no connection to Russia right I mean
there's no reason for Moscow to care
whether or not Colin Kaepernick gets
signed or you know him million during
national anthems but they understand
that it contributes to the political
discussion in the United States and that
it is a very easy way to inflame tension
so for now China appears to only engage
on issues that matter to them whereas
Russia is more advanced and more
aggressive and just likes to you know
get in the middle of things and mix it
up and you know that person yelling at
you on Twitter about Colin Kaepernick
could easily be a Russian troll believe
it or not so what's the more what's what
happens next year with the with Maury
and the NBA based on all that you've
gleaned on what obviously the NBA will
read your article with your colleagues
and try and put it all together with a
tip-off coming next Tuesday what do you
think happens been going yeah it's
amazing that the tip-off is already next
Tuesday but I do think that the height
of the conflict has passed right I mean
I think the worst is over for the league
and both sides seem to have retreated
from the brink a little bit and and kind
of us that the NBA has gone back to the
US China appears to have you know told
its state institutions to you know stop
going after the NBA the LeBron thing
this week course brought it up again a
little bit but I think basketball will
start and people will sort of forget
about it but there are huge consequences
for the league that I think the league
is still beginning to wrap its head
around this crisis and a lot of it is in
China's hands I mean it depends how far
they are willing to take this the
Rockets still have not been restored to
to China Chinese television or any other
streaming networks and you know I think
it's it's sort of crazy to say but you
know we don't know what
fallout of this will be for a very long
time and I think the league is still
trying to figure out what it all means
and I mean there are implications for
the salary cap for example that has been
discussed if if revenue from China which
you know until last week was the
league's most important foreign market
so there's so much uncertainty right now
and I think the league seems to be
pleased that it it weathered the storm
while they were there and now they just
have to figure out what comes next
alright Penn really appreciate the time
kudos to you and your colleagues for a
thought-provoking piece and and one that
adds a dimension to this that I don't
know and if anybody really was casting a
light on and how leagues I assume we'll
have to monitor social media from here
on out when they make huge decisions or
or or or take in the ramifications that
might not be real in a way yes it's a
totally new dimension of NBA Twitter
that's for sure
Ben thanks for the call appreciate it
thanks very much you got a Ben Cohen of
the Wall Street Journal go out and read
it how one tweet turned pro China trolls
against the NBA for more of the Rich
Eisen show tune
- audience Channel 239 on DirecTV for
free on BR Live or download the Rich
Eisen show app